und an diesem historischen tag weil wir
bei uns hier im studio claus strunz
begrüßen bild live chef verstehst du
hier bist warum ist dieser tag diese
debatte die heute geführt wird so
wichtig für deutschland bei leute das
parlament über das thema spricht was
alle interessiert worüber alle reden wir
über so unterschiedliche auffassungen
gibt ja man kann ja sogar fast sagen
über das thema das das land spaltet die
impfpflicht heute fallen die argumente
heute geht es auch darum dass
parlamentarier noch mal ins nachdenken
kommen ob sie mit ihrer idee wie sie
abstimmen wollen für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht oder gegen eine allgemeine
impfpflicht richtig liegen heute ist der
tag der demokratie dieser tag diese
debatte diese bilder diese
entscheidungen diese argumente gehen uns
alle an und es geht um viel es geht
darum was darf der staat dem einzelnen
anordnen und was nicht und sie verpassen
hierbei bild live nichts oben rechts
sehen sie das live bild aus dem
bundestag aber da läuft derzeit noch die
fragestunde zu wirtschafts- und
klimapolitik also sobald das mit der
impfpflicht debatte tatsächlich startet
verpassen sie natürlich hier bei bild
live nicht sie sehen es unten an den
leeren stuhl doch das ist der stuhl des
bundesgesundheitsministers und der ist
noch nicht besetzt also gleich geht das
erst dort im plenum im parlamentsgebäude
tatsächlich los mit der impfpflicht
debatte klaus aber wollen wir natürlich
von dir wissen was ist jetzt deine
meinung was ist deine meinung
impfpflicht ja oder nein ja ich schaue
da heute auf jede sekunde auf jede silbe
auf jedes argument ganz genau weil ich
hoffe und ich fordere und ich wünsche
mir dass dieses parlament zu der
entscheidung gelangt eine allgemeine
impfpflicht abzulehnen sie nicht
einzuführen im land weil ich glaube dass
sonst die im folgen die folgen dieser
pandemie weitaus schlimmer sind als die
pandemie selbst dann nämlich hat sich
der staat hat sich die politik etwas
herausgenommen was ihr nicht zusteht
oder lasst es mich so sagen noch nicht
zusteht weil sie verkleistert damit nur
dass sie bisher erfolglos war
deutschland schlechtes das
logistikunternehmen ist diese regierung
ist die politik deutschland
schlechtestes marketing unternehmen ist
diese regierung ist diese politik und es
können nicht die schlechtesten
logistiker und die schlechtesten
marketing menschen beschließen dass ihre
eigenen fehlleistungen nämlich dass sie
es nicht geschafft haben eine übergroße
mehrheit der menschen zum impfen zu
animieren dadurch wettmachen dass sie
befehlen dass man sich impfen lassen
muss das gibt mir so gegen den strich
und ich hoffe dass es in diesem
parlament der mehrheit gegen den strich
geht und dann kommt diese unsinnige
allgemeine impfpflicht nicht wir müssen
uns ganz genau anschauen was wurde klaus
alles unternommen um die menschen zum
impfen bewegen und es ist eine schlechte
marketing kampagne lasst uns das einmal
genauer anschauen das uns ansehen
ansehen was der bundeskanzler getan hat
um die menschen dazu zu bringen sich
impfen zu lassen
sie sehen hinter mir impfen hilft das
ist nur ein ganz kleiner auszug von dem
was wir uns vorgenommen haben es kommen
noch viele viele andere dazu vom radio
spot zur benutzung der
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten die sich mit
social media verbinden und alles
zusammen dazu beitragen dass die zahl
derjenigen die sich jetzt entschließen
sich das erste mal impfen zu lassen und
die zahl derjenigen die sich jetzt eine
auffrischungsimpfung polen noch mal
erheblich zunimmt ok also das sozusagen
das letzte zucken der bundesregierung in
sachen werbekampagne der allerletzte
versuch die menschen knapp 10 millionen
menschen zu erreichen die bisher gesagt
haben nach rund einem jahr den in dem
man sich impfen lassen kann mittlerweile
die immer noch sagen nie ich möchte das
nicht ich bin nicht überzeugt und dann
kommt der kanzler mit diesem plakat also
ich hab gestern dass sie es gesehen hab
mich damit befasst habe ich die ganze
zeit überlegt woher ich das kenne und
dann habe ich es bei twitter entdeckt
woher ich es kenne in einem vergleich
dann mache ich ja da machen wir autobank
toiletten bessere werbung sozusagen als
der bundeskanzler sanifair für das
freigeben kann hier sieht genau so aus
dass die gleiche farbpalette steht nur
ein bisschen was anderes drauf und ich
muss auch die frage stellen und auf
schulz hat hier wirklich einen geilen
wahlkampf gemacht also ich war jetzt
nicht sehr größter anhänger er aber der
wahlkampf war toll die botschaften waren
einfach die
mobilisierungskraft war riesig wenn olaf
scholz nur zehn prozent der kraft die
die menschen mobilisiert um ihn zu
wählen dazu aufbringen würde die
menschen die sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen doch noch dazu zu bringen dann
wäre das hilfe werde das ist ja nur der
peinlichste auf und lasst mich noch
eines sagen ich habe immer noch im kopf
erinnert ihr euch noch so ein bisschen
her wie die telekom-aktie beworben
worden ist da konnte man sich nicht
retten der hand einen die werbung bis
ins bett bis weiß wohin verfolgt da war
vor der tagesschau werbespot da war bei
heute in werbespot heute würde man sagen
da muss bei bild live im werbespot lauf
wo ist denn die millionenschwere
kampagne die die menschen erreicht das
hat die bundesregierung edk überlassen
die emotionen der menschen fürs impfen
auszulösen und erst wenn das geschehen
ist erst wenn alle maßnahmen ergriffen
sind erst wenn der bundeskanzler oder
der bundesgesundheitsminister
persönliche botschaften am besten kleine
videos an jeden bundesbürger geschickt
hat erst wenn streetworker ihre arbeit
gemacht haben in problemvierteln erst
wenn menschen rentner ältere menschen
die angst haben vielleicht überzeugt
haben mit argumenten
erst wenn das alles geschehen ist erst
wenn es eine impf prämie gibt erst wenn
das alles geschehen ist darf der staat
überhaupt dem gedanken näher treten ein
gesetz zu erlassen nachdem man sich
impfen lassen muss das ist das was mich
wirklich in rage bringt das eine nicht
tun und dann das andere verordnen da
würde ich sagen nicht mit uns und wir
haben gerade mit dem vergleich gesehen
das war schon eingeblendet der spanier
in frankreich zum beispiel die voll aufs
herz gezielt hat die mit kuss fotos
gearbeitet hat und gesagt hat mensch
also wenn wir alle geimpft sind da
können wir uns alle wieder richtung
liebhaber wisst ihr was sie beim
serviceteam was sie bei uns gemacht
hätten bei uns das ist ein perfektes
beispiel die franzosen sagen nennen wir
uns impfen können wir uns wieder
liebhaben hier würde man sagen vorsicht
kurs ansteckung das ist der große
unterschied das ist der unterschied
zwischen animieren für das gute und
angst machen der unterschied zwischen
animationen und angst politik und wir
sind halt auf der seite der angst
politik und ich bin mal gespannt das
parlament der teil unserer verfassung
der teil in diesem land von dem ich die
meiste hochachtung habe das sind unsere
stellvertreter die wir da rein gewählt
da sitzt auch übrigens der mensch mann
oder frau wichtig der mensch den ich in
meinem wahlkreis gewählt absitzt da
jetzt und ich bin mal sehr gespannt wie
er oder sie sich äußern wird und ob
wenigstens die bei denen man so fordern
freiheit denkt nämlich die liberalen
heute eine stunde der freiheit
zelebrieren mit argumenten gegen diese
impfpflicht also hat decke in sanifair
farben von autobahnraststätten reichen
nicht aus um menschen zum impfen zu
bewegen das meint claus strunz hier bei
uns im studio